why are we gonna bail out the airline
companies when they're doing all these
stock buybacks yeah he's my boy said
that and so I was yeah boys all he was
saying that and I said what's up with
the stock buybacks and so I went pretty
deep on understanding you know what what
are these buybacks cuz I only do at a
surface level one pretty interesting to
me so let me talk a little bit about
what's going on here so stock buybacks
started basically the Great Depression
so in 1928 the Depression happened stock
prices start crashing for a bunch of the
companies and the companies realize hey
normally when we want our stock price to
go up we got a generate more revenue
more customers more profits but with the
Great Depression happening those are
going down so our stock is dropping and
then the way that our stock is measured
revenue profits et cetera is gonna get
worse and it's just gonna cause a cycle
we're just gonna keep keeping keep
crashing so somebody very smart decided
oh I know what I can do if I want the
demand for my stock to go up I should
just limit the supply how do I do that
well what if I just use the cash we have
and rather than investing it in our
business to you know grow or do more
marketing or whatever I'm going to just
buy back shares so they started buying
back shares and they bought back shares
and then all of a sudden the there's
less shares available on the market and
the price started to buffer a price
started to go up and so this became like
immediately the the sort of silver
bullet solution that companies were
using to sort of survive in the Great
Depression now this is actually a
technique that Joseph Kennedy did with
there used to be a cab company called
Hertz which is now the car company and
this is exactly what he did
the founder of Hertz said Joe I need you
to lock it he was young and he goes he
was willing to break the rules because I
need you to lock yourself in this hotel
room up in New York and I need you to do
a lot of these buybacks so it appears as
though we are a lot bigger than we are
and then once the people start buying
them back sell them our stuff and you're
gonna ride a bus right exactly and you'd
just need to reverse the momentum and
the appearance that hey this company's
doing well in spite of everything else
and so when there's a you know when the
economy is crashing people fly toward
safety
flight to safe safe havens and so if
your stock is going up people will view
that as a safe haven and so anyways this
happens for a few years happens for six
years and then they put a stop to it so
the government comes out says hey we
will wait this is sort of an artificial
way to pump your stock price and we
don't like it we don't think it's a good
thing you're just buying they're
basically buying the management stock
itself so the management would sell the
stock using the company's own money so
the met the executive management would
get rich and the stock price would go up
and so the executive management keeps
their jobs so it was a double win so
1934 the stops and it stops for about I
don't know 50 years 50 years there's
basically no stock buybacks
in the stock market now 1982 comes
around you have Reagan as the president
and there's this guy John Chad and I
don't know exactly what his deal was but
but they decided that hey you know what
we should they change they were they
wrote a new law which allowed stock
buybacks back back into play
company should be able to do this and
the theory was hey here's what will
happen when a company buys back its
shares they can use you know they can
use some of that back a company could
use its cash to do three things at any
given time it can give it to the
employees and raise their wages they can
invest in growth hire new employees or
invest in machines and whatnot or they
can issue a dividend to investors and
that's the sort of buy background and so
what end up happening was Reagan writes
his law into pass so 1982 buybacks are
back after 50 years and the second
change that happened was that CEO
started kidding compensated not on
salary but also based off of bonuses for
the share price so now the CEO is also
incentivized to buffer the sale to stock
price and so you go from in 1980 to half
a percent of profits were spent on
buybacks before this law 2008 77 percent
of profits are used for stock buybacks
even now it's 65 percent so 65 percent
of profits not going to employee wages
not going into investing for growth just
you announcing stock buybacks and you
can see that the CEO compensation is
sort of skyrocketed as well so we went
from the CEO used to make 15 times more
the
the average employee at their company
now it's 220 times more because they're
compensated on the stock price and the
stock buyback is the easiest way to
buffer the stock price and so this has
been getting worse and worse and worse
2008 was sort of that peak worst time
because when the financial crash
happened in 2008 companies they pulled
their favorite lever to keep their stock
price high or from plummeting further
and so recently Trump cut the corporate
tax from 37 percent to 21 percent and
the idea again was like alright great if
we don't tax the companies they'll use
that money to give higher wages to
reinvest in the business and they did a
study they saw that it's been a year and
a half since that tax cut and wages have
gone up 1.2 percent only but there's
been one trillion dollars of stock
buybacks and now it's since then and so
clearly the the reason the companies
asked for the tax cut is not why they
did this and what do you think is gonna
happen so I think what's gonna happen is
now there's a there's a problem right so
these companies like the airline
industry right so I have this graph that
we can show on the screen for people who
watch this on Instagram or on the
YouTube channel for the Hustle which by
the way for some reason nobody watches
on YouTube even though it's much better
we cut the clips of just the good parts
and you see the video you see the graphs
so I don't know why nobody's watching
but they should the podcast gets way
more listeners than that but anyways
there's this graph that shows okay if
you look at like international companies
outside the US where you know at
Volkswagen or whatever they'll have like
0% stock buybacks if you look at in the
US some of the corporations like United
eighty percent of profits went to to
stock buybacks Southwest 66% Delta fifty
percent of profits being used on this so
now these companies they don't have cash
anymore because they bought back their
own worthless shares so they've ran out
of cash because they were buying back
their shares to pump their price and now
they can't do it because the whole
economy's crashing so now they can't get
their way out of that and they don't
have the cash to withstand this so
they're gonna go to the government say
hey we're all out of cash don't let us
fail but really should we reward that
because you used all your cash to buy
back stock to make yourself rich for the
last five years well by the way we know
of us
gonna end yeah you're gonna get bailed
out and they're gonna do the same thing
sadly it's yeah this is I didn't know I
didn't know about a lot of that so
there's our clip
[Music]